file this one under why would you ever
trust politicians to do anything about
your life i really
it is a source of constant bewilderment
that you look at the institutional
players in your life and you think me
these people need more authority they
need more authority
okay because let's just face it most of
the people who are in congress at this
point are there for the instagram of it
they're there for the public attention
of it and they're not super competent at
their jobs and so i don't take them very
seriously because i don't think that
they're worthy of being taken seriously
this goes across the board okay it seems
to me that whenever you see congress
people who are pretending to be offended
by each other it's all for show
whether it is aoc on the floor of the
house
yelling about how
wha what the hell what the hell is that
that congressman's name from arizona
gosar well whether it was aoc standing
on the floor of congress shouting about
how paul gosar threatened her life with
an anime meme or whether it is ilhan
omar complaining that lauren bilbert
made up made a bad and cruel joke about
her being a terrorist i just i i i find
a ha i'm having a hard time carrying
i've got to be honest with you i have a
real hard time with congress people who
spend their lives complaining that
people make fun of them
and use anime memes like welcome to the
real world where this kind of crap
happens all the time
yeah i'm i'm not aware of many public
figures who receive more of this stuff
than i do and frankly i don't care
because i have a real life and you know
what i can do i can shut off my phone
and if somebody says something mean and
nasty about me eh
that's life
but these congress people are
simultaneously some of the biggest mouth
thin skinned people i've ever seen in my
entire life and it's so obnoxious so
we've had an entire national controversy
now over the fact that lauren bober did
a did an event
where she made a joke about ilhan omar a
mildly inappropriate joke about how she
said that ilhan omar was a was a bomber
or something
okay now is that a joke that politicians
should tell about each other no probably
not
is it the end of the world is it
something that you should spend even one
iota of energy on today
no and frankly if we are going to rank
crimes by congress members i'm going to
go with the congress member who says
openly anti-semitic things routinely who
has expressed support for terror groups
who has written letters to judges
attempting to lessen the sentence of
people who are being recruited to isis i
feel like that's a lot worse than lauren
bover making a bad joke about that
person i'm just gonna put that out there
okay but apparently this is now such an
issue the democrats are considering
stripping lauren bober of her committee
assignment now let's just be real about
this democrats have entered into a game
that they do not want to play because
congress will be controlled by
republicans come january 2023 and when
that happens ilhan omar will not be on
the foreign affairs committee eric
swallow will not be on the intelligence
committee since he was banging a chinese
spy we are not going to be having a lot
of democratic members of congress who
are currently sitting maxine waters is
not going to be on financial services
that lady is corrupt as the day is long
now the rule was it used to be that
parties got to select which of their own
members got to sit on which committee
that rule is in place because you really
didn't want one party dictating to the
other party who its prominent members
would be
but democrats have broken that rule
because they've stripped a bunch of
republican congress members of their
committee assignment even if i think
those members are bad i don't think it's
up to democrats to strip the opposing
party of their committee assignment so
if we're going to play this game because
now democrats want to do this to lauren
bober over this joke that we're about to
play for you then um ilhan omar is
likely to find herself out in the cold
come january 2023 as she should be so
anyway here is the original joke that
lauren bobert told obviously so bad so
terrible end of world let's all weep for
ilhan omar
i was getting into an elevator with one
of my staffers
and he and i are we're leaving the
capitol we're going back to my office
and we get an elevator and i see a
capitol police officer
running hurriedly
to the elevator i see fret all over his
face and he's reaching and i'm like
the door's shutting like i can't i can't
open it look what's happening
i look to my left and there she is
ilhan omar
and i said well
she doesn't have a backpack we should be
fine
okay uh so she makes a joke about el
hanar being being a terrorist or
whatever
okay so ilhan omar acts like she is very
very upset about this how dare anybody
how dare anybody uh a woman who once
said that something happened on 9 11
something happened to some people on 9
11. she's never said anything offensive
oh and omar again does that mean that
lauren bobert told the world's greatest
joke there is that a joke that she
should apologize for you know on a
personal level the way that this
typically should work is she should call
up you know i don't think she owes the
public an apology i think
there's this routine in politics now
where if you say something mean to
somebody you don't know them an apology
you owe the public an apology you don't
know the public in apology i think the
public can take care of itself but you
know she called up
she called up bill and omar to try and
be a nice person and offered her an
apology and apparently ilhan omar then
played the wronged innocent and uh and
hung up on her here is lauren bober
telling that story
she said that she still wanted a public
apology because what i had done wasn't
good enough so i reiterated to her what
i had just said she kept asking for a
public apology so i told ilhan omar that
she should make a public apology to the
american people for her anti-american
anti-semitic anti-police rhetoric she
continued to press and i continued to
press back and then representative omar
hung up on me
rejecting an apology and hanging up on
someone is part of cancel culture 101 in
a pillar of the democrat party
okay so
me
so there there'll be a lot of words
spilled over this a lot of ink spilled
over this a lot of talk about democrats
are now seriously considering again
stripping lauren baldberger for
committee assignment over this over like
all right i mean like
i'm i'm not going to pretend that i care
at all because i frankly do not i do not
i do love how old and omar characterized
this conversation quote today i
graciously accepted a call from
representative lauren well i mean don't
pat yourself on the back too hard there
lady i mean her arm has stretched six
inches just so she could properly reach
her back she graciously she didn't just
accept a phone call she graciously
accepted a phone call what a hero what a
hero in the hope of receiving a direct
apology for falsely claiming she met me
in an elevator suggesting i was a
terrorist and for a history of
anti-muslim hate instead of apologizing
for islamophobic comments and fabricated
lies representative boba refused to
publicly acknowledge her hurtful and
dangerous comments she instead doubled
down on her rhetoric and i decided to
end the unproductive call i believe in
engaging with those we disagree with
respectfully no you don't in what world
is this true of ilhoon omar but not when
that disagreement is rooted in outright
bigotry and okay so here is the dynamic
dynamic in congress is that our congress
people have every incentive to be social
media stars and very little incentive to
actually just do public service
and so
this benefits everybody in the end this
benefits everybody it benefits people
who tell you jokes it benefits people
who get very offended it benefits the
media that loves to cover it
does any of it make your life better of
course not and should you spend one
again one ounce of energy over the
offense being taken by members of
congress that other members of congress
are saying mean things about them not
one shred of energy should you spend
today on this not one shred so i only
wish to point this out because i wish to
point out that you the american people
have decided to give more of these
people power over your life and i don't
understand why i will never understand
why
who's got two thumbs and wants you to
like and subscribe